That's life found throughout the skeleton.
It is the most important of the blood corpuscle factory.
Every day, 200 billion red blood corpuscles, 15 billion white blood corpuscles,
and 500 billion platelets are produced.
Everything starts inside a big master cell,
which regulates its production according to the blood requirements of the body.
Many different foods flow to the cell's energy factories.
These are the ribosomes, or the assembly line tables of the protein.
Multiplied by three thousand equals, hmm, sixteen hundred and fourteen, hmm.
Two hundred what, Chief?
No, no, that can't be right.
Three hundred and fourteen thousand what, Chief?
Four hundred thousand and, uh, gah, can't you see I'm doing arithmetic?
Don't bother me!
What arithmetic, Chief?
The number of nucleotides we need to make one red blood corpuscle, you great big idiot.
Then all I have to do is multiply that figure by two hundred, now where was I?
Two hundred what, Chief?
Two hundred billion red blood cells!
The system must produce 200 billion red blood corpuscles a day.
Get that?
Two, three, four, 200 billion.
It's a lot. Really a lot.
Don't you think it's time to warn the maestro?
Maestro, but can't you see he's occupied?
Oh, well.
That's his way of concentrating, you see.
Look there.
So what?
Well, we're nearly at 200 billion.
200 billion what?
200 billion red blood cells.
That's our daily quota.
That's what our body needs!
What the matter with you, you mustn't kick the equipment!
Just look what you've done! Because of you, there's one too many!
Don't worry, you two. First of all, life is order, right?
Give or tune it, of course.
But always respect the equipment, that's part of the order.
100 billion. All present correct.
100 billion plus one.
What a joy it is to see them, little corpuscles!
Now you'll be able to circulate oxygen, just like the big red blood cells.
Ooh!
Settled as far as the red cor-
Cells, our oxygen carriers are concerned.
Let's take a look at the white blood cells, our body's police force.
Hmm.
We need them all the time.
See, where are they?
Why don't you look here?
But who allowed that to happen?
Of course! Fifteen billion of them!
Wait, Maestro, it's all done automatically.
Production is automatic, true, but we must monitor it all the time.
Error here could be fatal.
Why's that, Maestro?
The white blood cells have powerful weapons to defend the body.
If there's an error in programming, their weapons can be turned on the body itself, you see.
But how on earth could that kind of error happen?
We can't say, it's still a mystery. Everything is programmed in the chromosomes.
But the plan can be disrupted, that's why we keep watch.
All the programming is done here in the chromosomes.
That stupid game immediately, do you hear me?
It is crazy! He's fooling around with heredity programming!
This is insane, quite insane.
Triction enzymes, ligase enzymes to work immediately.
We've got to repair this at once, oh yeah.
And have yourself recycled immediately, and never play with genes again, do you hear?
But here before the team.
Here after the A.
Again, the C's not in the right place.
Or is it double G?
Let's verify the DNA message.
Excellent repair work, just like the original.
Send an RNA messenger to have more white corpuscles produced, thank you.
Blood cell.
Maestro, maestro, we still have to make 500 billion platelets!
Go to load up some more oxygen.
I've still got some room.
Wait till we get to the lungs.
First we must deliver the oxygen we're carrying to the cell.
Then we must get rid of the carbon dioxide.
Is it my oxygen?
We must share everything, mustn't we?
Huh?
Having fun.
Captain Peter Jr., traffic is moving steadily in the sector without any problems.
All our body sentinels are at their posts.
Nothing to report, Colonel.
Okay, Captain.
Make use of this opportunity, shall we, to give our young pilots a bit of practice.
Flu viruses are reported in Zone 14, the mucous membrane of the nose.
There aren't too many of them, and anyway, we're vaccinated.
So give instructions to get rid of them as quickly as possible.
I'll do so at once, Colonel.
Calling B lymphocyte XO unit.
Calling unit XO.
Flu virus alert, type unknown.
Zone 14 nasal mucous membrane.
Immediate reconnaissance.
Over and out.
Zone 14 of nasal mucus, flu virus, type unknown, immediate verification, all Able-B lymphocytes take off immediately, take off immediately.
Straight ahead, virus be revived.
It's okay, exactly what they are. Everything's under control, you can go back now.
You might as well go and finish your breakfast.
Antibodies specific to virus 113B, ready? Let's get them!
Now it's time to multiply.
Concluded with Colonel, vaccination proved 100% effective. Macrophages will clear the site. Over and out.
This is a general alert. General alert. There's a rebellion in the body police force. Our troops are no longer obeying orders.
There's a more full of them, don't you think?
That's right. Surely they must know what they're doing up there.
Should now be busy making platelets. But we're stuck with white blood cells.
But maybe we need a lot of white blood cells.
A lot? But just look over there.
Got far too many. Fifteen times too many.
Calling restriction enzymes. It's absolutely essential to reduce production.
Hurry immediately! Urgent! Urgent!
And... hurry up!
It's not normal.
I tell you, not normal.
Stop!
You're blocking the traffic, now you must go this way.
You must follow the rules like everybody else.
Follow the rules?
We don't know any.
What do you want?
Just a minute, please, you HLA cards.
Here's my card. Do you dig?
No, I don't dig. You're different.
You're not the same type.
Not for this body.
You're the one who's not the same type.
Come on, boys!
Go!
Near the heart wind is bowed and blocked my way from the situation.
After an emotional moment or two when I thought I was a goner...
Savages!
I don't believe it! What do they think they are?
Behavior from the police. I wonder if they're normal.
The white blood cells attack the population of their own organism.
It's not normal. It's an illness.
That's what I think.
Is that bad?
Oh, yes, that can be very bad.
Little one, lie down and I'll call the duck.
That's her, me little girl. Where are you hurting most?
Well, Doc.
Oh, we'll have to do a blood test.
That hurt?
No, just a tiny little prick.
Ah, now we'll have this analysed to see what's making you miserable.
I'll be back soon.
Cells rioting.
The anarchists.
Is it serious, Doctor?
Yes, Piret, very.
A disease of the blood.
Leukemia.
The white cells are unbalanced.
They've become attackers, not protectors.
Can we do, Doctor?
We'll destroy the bad elements in the blood, and unfortunately, some good ones, too.
But let me assure you that today we can often cure these diseases.
And your young Peter will prove to be a great help.
Now, we must move her to a sterile room.
There's no doubt about it.
This is very serious anemia.
Destruction of red blood cells and platelets and rapid multiplication of rampant white blood cells.
We must hurry.
Destroy all the corpuscles.
Fortunately, we're well armed.
As I told you, dear, it's a very serious disease of the blood.
Probably will.
But if all goes well, the body won't die.
What? Doesn't it need us?
No, the body will have to make more of our own kind.
Life's impossible without us.
So everything will be done.
And we'll still all carry on sharing oxygen?
Yes.
Oh, I love fresh air.
Impossible.
Bodies, sentinels destroyed.
Corpuscles, the energy carriers, decimated.
The bone marrow factory destroyed.
Production, zero.
Organisms, defense, zero.
The advantage of the situation is that all the wild white cells have been destroyed
and their factories in ruins.
Now, we can start again.
Anarchistic cells have been eliminated and production ended.
But now she has no defense against germs and microbes.
We must provide her with other defenses, and nobody can do that better than her brother.
What do you mean?
Well, he can give her bone marrow cells.
They're healthy and have the same HLA, or characteristics, as his sisters.
They'll help us reconstruct what we've destroyed.
Ah, here's young Peter.
You'll see it won't be sore.
Just a tiny little prick there.
I'm scared of injections, but I do want her cured, so go ahead.
Oh, Peter.
Stroh?
For one of life's miracles, the cells I've injected will go on an extraordinarily long journey.
See?
From the vein in the arm, they go up to the heart.
From there, right ventricle pushes them into the pulmonary aorta, and they pass through the lungs.
Then, they're projected into general circulation.
The big arteries and the fine arteries.
They carry on and only stop when they find themselves in the bone marrow.
It's as if they've always known that they had to go there and nowhere else.
Working! The production lines are functioning perfectly!
We've won!
Look at that!
Everything in order!
Have to be patient for a while, but everything's fine.
Didn't I love it so?
Chalet cards, please.
Carry on now.
It's fine.
I think we're quite safe now.